intelligence officials say attacks like
those in Paris require significant
logistical expertise but not necessarily
all that much money
Islamic state seemingly has both the
group has ambitions to be an independent
state and today controls large portions
of both Syria and Iraq and even though
the attacks in Paris may not have needed
much capital sustaining an enormous
global operation does so here's a look
at how Islamic state makes its money in
the territories that occupies the
group's members rob banks levy taxes on
transited Goods and extort cash from
ordinary citizens according to data from
alleged Islamic state financial
documents confiscation otherwise known
as theft makes up almost 45% of the
group's revenue that totals about 3.7
million dollars a month taxation
accounts for about 24% almost two
million dollars a month the Islamic
state controls much of water on Syria's
oil fields and refineries the US
Treasury Department estimates that
before the American bombing campaign on
Syrian refineries began in September
2014 Islamic state was earning as much
as two million dollars a day from oil
sales the group was able to rebuild and
adapt its facilities and in November
2015 the US Treasury said the group was
still earning 40 million dollars a month
in oil sales that's 1.3 million dollars
a day
Islamic state militants have taken
thousands of civilians hostage some of
them are executed but many more are
ransomed for financial gain the US
Treasury Department estimates that
Islamic state made between twenty and
forty five million dollars in kidnap and
ransom during 2014 the Islamic state
solicits money from supporters around
the world and in 2014 the US Treasury
Department estimates the group made five
million dollars from foreign donations
early in the spring of 2015 a suburban
mother from Chicago together with five
others was indicted for sending military
equipment and money to terrorist
organizations including Islamic state
and in October 2015 in Cologne Germany
members of a gang were charged with
stealing twenty-one thousand five
hundred dollars from local churches and
schools when sending that money to
Islamic state the militants now control
territory in Iraq and Syria that
historically has produced half of
Syria's wheat crop and a third of Iraq's
those fields taken with 40% of Iraq's
barley supply could earn the militants
200 million dollars a year the group's
diverse revenue streams is what sets it
apart from other terrorist organizations
like al Qaeda that group depends on a
small network of wealthy donors this
difference means that Islamic states
funds keep flowing even if individual
sources sometimes dry up but after the
Paris attacks political leaders around
the world are seriously focused on how
to permanently cut off all of the
group's revenue streams
[Music]